[Music]
before vaccine is approved for use in
the united states
the vaccine is tested extensively in
clinical trials the results from these
clinical trials help determine if the
vaccine
is safe and effective the u.s food and
drug administration
fda looks at the results from these
clinical trials before determining
whether the vaccine can be approved for
use in the united states
vaccines contain only the ingredients
they need to be safe
and effective there are many different
ingredients in vaccines
each ingredient serves a specific
purpose some ingredients
may provide immunity which is protection
against the disease
some ingredients may help keep the
vaccine safe
and long-lasting and some ingredients
may be included because they are used
when producing the vaccine
let's go over these three types of
ingredients in more detail
the first type of ingredient we will
talk about are ingredients that help a
person's immune system
respond to and build immunity against a
specific disease
examples of this kind of ingredient are
antigens which are very small amounts of
weak
or dead germs that can cause diseases
antigens help your immune system learn
how to fight off infections faster and
more effectively
another example of a vaccine ingredient
that helps a person build immunity
are adjuvants adjuvants which are in
some vaccines
are substances that help your immune
system respond more strongly to a
vaccine
this means that you may have increased
immunity against a disease
the second type of ingredient we will
talk about are ingredients that help
keep vaccines safe and long-lasting
these ingredients help make sure that
the vaccine continues to be safe
and work like it's supposed to work they
also help make sure that germs and
bacteria
don't get into the vaccine an example of
this type of ingredient is a
preservative
which protects the vaccine from outside
bacteria or
fungus preservatives are usually only
used in vaccines that have more than one
vaccine dose in each vial or container
preservatives are used in these vaccines
because each time an individual dose of
the vaccine is taken from the vial
it's possible for harmful germs to get
inside the vial most vaccines are
available in single dose biles and do
not have
preservatives in them another example of
this type of ingredient
are stabilizers like sugar or gelatin
these ingredients help the active
ingredients of vaccines continue to work
while the vaccine is made stored and
moved around
one example of how stabilizers work is
that they keep the
active ingredients in vaccines from
changing if there's a shift in
temperature in the area
where the vaccine is being stored the
third type of ingredient we will talk
about are ingredients that are used
during the production of vaccines
sometimes ingredients that are needed to
produce a vaccine
are no longer needed for the vaccine to
work when it's given to a person
these ingredients are taken out of the
vaccine after it's produced
so only a very small amounts are left in
the vaccine
these small amounts of ingredients that
remain in the vaccine aren't harmful to
people
examples of ingredients that are used
during the production of vaccine
include cell cultural material which
helps grow the vaccine
antigens inactivating ingredients which
weaken or kill viruses bacteria
or toxins in the vaccine and antibiotics
which help keep outside germs and
bacteria from growing in the vaccine
all of these ingredients are used to
make vaccines all vaccines go through a
lot of testing before the fda approves
them
for use in the united states you can
feel confident that any vaccine you
receive is safe and effective
let's review what we just discussed and
go over some of the key points
vaccines contain only the ingredients
they need to be
safe and effective each ingredient in a
vaccine
serves a specific purpose ingredients
and vaccines provide immunity against
disease
keep a vaccine safe and long-lasting and
are tested before they are used so the
vaccine is safe and effective
you